[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you let me know if you hear me check I
actually might turn the music down cuz I
know that music kind of loud for a
second really the first second what's
going on yeah let me know what's going
on we do some testing right now I got
attic muted so what's going on soon
I no doubt yo shout-out to all my team
music file a super chat man much
appreciated brother I got the hype going
got me high you know then you know let
me know um you attic talk to him and let
him know if they gave you know that
guess I would say technically that's a
sticker it's not a super check
oh yeah that's you gotta give up his
love man watching music music so we get
way for people to get in run a little
baby running late it's cuz I've been
having some technical issues and I think
we still gotta patreon the days there's
a lot of stuff going on but what's up
y'all good to see ally here and let me
know if notifications and stuff is on
coming through and you too I saw a
couple I said that so be which are in a
minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right and we are live talk to people
addict make sure they can hear you make
sure they make sure they get Hagan can
you guys hear me oh wow shout this video
I got the Smitty super Chester Luke
salutations Lord scriptures inbound the
book of Acts a hundred and fourteen us
in the chat oh yes and thank you YouTube
notifications again for all those that
didn't know please you don't say hit
that loud notification Bell make sure
you know when we're live we've been
having issues for the past two weeks so
we really appreciate it
so on that note and we are live welcome
to the island lures podcast and the
Lords of gaming dotnet episode number
152 there's no the glorious Sunday we're
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got Phil Spencer's
interview last of us to delayed and
gearbox bonuses to discuss so we go get
right into it
I want to introduce a Lord whose content
I first came across through true friends
of the Rome Lawrence Nintendo guru and
simply ghosts and mr. Babbitt know is
just not one of the most positive
energetic content creators in the realm
but it's infectious your and outstanding
passion for video games make him an
absolute must listen don't shake your
head cuz it's you
introducing the created host of the Wii
the gamer cast and co-host of the Xbox
drive and coupler Joe and Nintendo
podcast the Lord of you
and Capri and a member of the reverb
dirty movement laughs from Alberta
Canada and making his debut into the
realm of the Lord's mom made Lord Zhang
Capri how he does sir
I was so nervous about the intro thing I
just I just I'm a humble Canadian I just
come here but perfect timing to jump on
in here we've got Nintendo love we've
got Xbox love I have a Playstation
around here some love some show could
breathe what you got dish you got some
most clothes around let's just like grab
like my favorite thing to do is just
pause whatever podcast it is whatever
topic is love the energy van long over
you you know we obviously like we said
before we both had some mutual friends
and I came across a contact fantastic
content plus you deal with Bobby so you
know God I got it gotta say love I mean
I kind of changed my life to like he him
and I met he was Muse I think the fourth
or fifth guest on we the gamer cast like
years and years ago and we just like we
hit it off man we're just looking into
each other's eyes the relationship and
the Guru but have you been playing sir
oh dude I I feel like I had a hell of I
mean a lot of us had a hell of a March
but um I wrapped up Orion doom and like
between those two games like it's pretty
intense dude it was kind of a lot just
to take you know motion of Ori and then
just rip everything in half and do my I
needed I need a bit of a break guys
yeah little bit overwhelmed don't you
know what I mean like I've laid them too
to finish them and yeah like I just
raised through doom and I just need a at
this moment I'm taking a breath and I
I'm I'm playing a game that a lot of
people know about it's pretty popular
Japanese you played this cute little
character you're on an island you get to
like craft things you get some sounds
like a boat crossing damn it has cloud
saves playing at Dragon Quest builders
two men it's been that up over on the
old switch and that way Dona miasma I'm
serious on an island right now like this
yeah and I've got a dog now her name is
Charlie just like my dog and in the
little character after my daughter Ellie
so she's going off on all these amazing
adventures though I'm loving it man I
but Bobby and I don't we almost broke up
because you ain't playing Animal
Crossing that's what that is well we had
a fight a while ago we may have the
whole when they were talking about the
no no cloud saves in the whole one
island purse which for copy and all
night right I don't like that I think I
should be on the plane wherever I go I
mean my wife and I each have a like if
we have one copy I should put one into
her switch she plays it I gotta stop you
right quick shout out to Bobby aka the
girls from the show this guy is lost in
the sauce I just had to get my I didn't
Bobby's voice give me the pies because I
know I'm one in a trillion everybody on
the planet is playing Animal Crossing so
I realize I'm like the only person is
like wow actually I don't like stand on
your square it's okay to go against the
movement to resist the move in this
house my wife plays it and my son plays
and they're going crazy with it and so
like even if you're gonna vote with your
wallet like they still got the one
coffee out of an ally in this in this
certain thing look no further
yes resistant so we guys have a lot of
stuff to talk about great to have you in
the room but you already know we got the
Four Horsemen of gaming those original
Lords in the realm here at the round
table
my co-host the coal mouse my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror
Lord of reviews and the Haab of the
young wolf not me
Lord addict guy you do is a pretty good
actually you know I actually played like
almost 40 hours of persona this week
really yeah it's definitely I don't like
none of that school stuff joining the
game you're like yeah like I literally
press Start and I just let they like
what's funny is like when I'm skipping
through it I imagine they sound like
amble cross I gotta go the Christmas
that's the techno for robbing you blood
in the bushes while snitch [ __ ] is not
gonna like this the switch talk today we
got a lot of switch gang in here we got
to show Capri in here we got we got
Tendo guru in here he's good he's gonna
be upset this this is what about biggest
haters with Animal Crossing yes continue
continue Atticus are they straight out
of your pocket not giving you a good
product animal Crossing's not for me
well I see it but I recognize that is
your normal Punk 22 2077 right I mean
I'm just talking about that's what you
looking forward to another platform
previews previews anyway on the show you
made the bet you forgot
what was happening though oh yeah
Bobby's on you he said that you said
attic isn't a fan of Animal Crossing aka
good Gabe's hell Bobby on this don't
know Bobby said or he wasn't a good game
he called hot trash in the summer oh
yeah we gotta get over for a little oil
right cool hey Tori come on good a beer
a with addict so besides that you do any
persona you'd be yelling for soda for me
and all that stuff did you said you did
all that you do it up so what else you
were playing Liz it like I've been
dabbling in destiny but not no doubt and
of course happy that he made it in cuz
he's not feeling well we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo game list
for the single player selfish experience
and also the sastra Thomas mr. Othman
profile Illuminati and lore picture of
the I baked mommy bought sovereign now
he doing sir what's good guys chillin
man keeping keeping my voice low you
know I don't have those I have to
strengthen my voice to yella addict glad
you're still able to make it in the
realm you know I'm saying but just real
quickly so we could say voice anything
you guys have to play anything there's a
lot this week I got a chance to finish
um finally got a chance to finish all in
order
wow wow yeah I didn't realize how do you
feel about it I thought it was I mean it
was typical like you know summer
blockbuster ending was very cool working
your voice early song working your voice
early you don't like anything subtle you
like to be smacked in the face look us
off try to direct the conversation no
angry angry angry operas every bounce
off is feisty I like this song you will
get 15 bars with strong problem level
boss I think the best example of playing
as a Jedi in the game that I'm seeing
you know a lot of people say unleashes
better and I think they're like smoking
something they're not unleash unleash
unleash was cool but unleashes and his
refined gameplay wise Oh photo hold I
got a dota crest up super chat shout out
to dizzy $5 super jet even my man Jay
dub is on Animal Crossing that man
Bastion Animal Crossing went wild one
already hurt and making it worse why
when you get your copy of Final Fantasy
7 remake adding a shoddy Disney baby's a
completely unrelated game shepherds were
shot down brother Disney made definitely
go into his treatment see what I'm
saying
solutely I know he's not you know door
well to me do a little better but I know
he's going through it right now so
salute EDD for even being here but
continue solemn circle oh yes so besides
the once I finish that I hop back into
doom yeah I just beat the second Hill
priest and I'm like the setup that
entire stage a setup literally showing
you how they construct the boss that is
going to fight you at the end I've never
seen a setup in a stage where they they
put the boss on this pedestal like like
when you get to this duel you're in
trouble and they show you how they put
him together like the state is so
masterfully built worried like crazy
best days I've honestly I remember
playing this stage that I was like wow
this is insane how're they doing I can't
go front solve the the the I will watch
a lot of podcast and like a lot of
people's clips for the gameplay is a
duel
and I'm about talking straw glass
because I'm holding now yours this man
ok come on feel feel I need it again I'm
sorry you did good with the best have
you played the first one though if you
play play the first one just to give you
a nice trophy of the baby yeah and you
see there you go no I'll go do that cuz
person you end up point by you in a
second it's really good just go play a
game
kiss bull was with me he wait no game I
bet is that good and the first one is
fantastic but if you happen to play the
second one before the first you know I
want to go back to the first oh wow well
I heard that it's so drastically
improved mmm you just can't do it so
that's I said that's all I'll be fraud
in anyway so drastically improve its
like a completely different game it's
gonna make that game past play even way
better and baby guess what awake bring
wakefulness Maximus
I gave me I guess I gave it to you
so there's a pretty legit solve be doing
at home hold on stitch again with some
more switch slander okay Isis I'll be
attic you want to get that one but throw
that can we get a trash emo for the
Nintendo topics please so we can you
know for four stitches sake man you know
definitely one we need a fraud alert a
watch the pockets and into the butcher
and get the fraud you got the frog is he
Freud right there he definitely pocket
watches Lord Lord Dido playboy do 2016
and eternal aces
let me tell you a story about this man
the dealer game so I joined the party
last night I just got off work uh you
know what wanting to run the chill and
he don't talk for 10-15 minutes as ran
in their fawns and then he just randomly
talks and he's like yeah I'm like what
he's like are you playing are you
playing that that that what doom
internal sound like Dracula you know
what you're doing out expect it from me
a final fantasy next we said but there's
a difference I'm like wait you're wrong
oh yeah I go for the do listen even even
let's shout the Lord Lord show Capri
even I was listening to to him talk
about you were raving about it and
everyone everyone's loved it will happen
happens but you know and we'll cross it
another things happen because you know
why snitch you know why dealer switch
anyway we gotta move of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer the little girl best sports
kid of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord kill ego we do exam you
guys are out of control or Twitter y'all
are absolutely out of control
hey so yo King what no WrestleMania and
I literally said man I don't care about
wrestling nowadays job no no no he lost
the match to some do be put them over
and they do beat him in a couple of
second
something I heard yeah these are CBS
recap and you know how mister man got
they don't know super lock go and check
that out I let you buy somebody before
you go into useful you were really
really enjoying that the synapses
breakdown of how this man is really just
killed Superman and how oh he's a
knockoff of Hulk enough like you were
really in your bag I gotta say you're
you're in your bag of the thrashing of
how Superman was thrashed was hilarious
I just had to give it up to you exactly
what I really felt about to do you know
I don't like super sent that much you
know so it had to take something of a
the caliber of a fake Incredible Hulk to
break him in and um I love the fact that
they did do that and then I didn't also
go into the the Kryptonian origins of
doomsday because I didn't think that was
fitting for my synapses of why I got
this statue but trust me um there's
another doomsday that is probably here
or either coming I gotta check the box
this morning and I will talk about the
new 50 tools rendition on how they try
the retcon all that you know that went
down when he got his bombastic smashing
yeah nobody but the bony Hawk over here
but um which replace her what I've been
playing shut out the game pass and Lou
Lord filled Damas Maximus dispenser with
what's going on a releases index see
what it is
Oh like you are sure today today my
timeline has been very quiet a lot of
you little generals out here for this
PlayStation nation the Little Ponies and
let's listen I got
a Playstation and I spent probably
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
PlayStation so I could say whatever I
want about getting started in this
generation I'm a slam to you today shout
out to my man VG for saying that he
wanted y'all to cry shout out to my man
BG I love your video BG w G if ya VG's
hilarious yes Larry
okay so shout out to Nana
yes I did like the best version of the
game right I'll be coming oh god I love
that I was playing bleeding-edge I
played that and then I was playing this
little Jim that I found in the bushes
I'm getting passed call Wes Toronto all
right I've been on my little indie cape
right because why I can do it because
financially I was never gonna buy that
game mm-hmm you know I was it was it was
a try
what well Phil said he called that game
is so funny
he was so yo you could pull you could be
a mid conversation with a dude and pull
a gun out like you're my man like stop
that games I'm just getting started
on it and I'm just loving the fact that
I'm able to sample these stuff during
this you know of situations wait you in
a house and you want something where I
think this is showing an uptake in video
game usage and a digital content being
consumed globally because we can't
really go to stores we don't you can't
stay on lines and aims stop is closed so
I really
the fact their game passes you showing
you know it's coming into its own right
now because it's being used I'm pretty
sure if you have an xbox want to save
some money in these economic economic
crisis times right now this is a good
venue and a good value for your wallet
I'm no doubt nah for real and I'm glad
you said that because at the end of the
day it's like we were saying like being
a gamer right Sean right it's it's
almost awesome for us because we this is
what we do and table to handle periods
like this cuz we can go we have this
outlet right isn't it like really cool
that we have this outlet is gaming
waiting for this yes are you doing this
like my whole life pretty late yeah joke
like were they like corty go to work at
home like fam I've been doing that I'm
good yo shout out the photo to Chad he
said I really appreciate kin going with
the comic accurate statue and not to be
the VVS atrocity and thank you because
that's what I felt it was it was needed
that you even even recognized that
because we'll just be and you see the
status of the character you will
understand exactly why I went with this
version over the other version Oh attic
we have a super chat search from
spinning fish so we got a photo from
Smitty's
I know at the time a lot of ponies are
unemployed right now right sure I got
work for you the book at this time I
can't really like you know I fill the
book except Phil I fill the enthusiast
percent but I don't feel the best but
everybody Kingsman in there and of
course we have the cable into himself
the shinobi lore incognito spring that
realness in the Robin ILP not telling
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear so arm yet man for me man oh
shout out to our dog a little trials in
shop to send us to shout to screen you
know I'm saying we got it in so we
didn't get really hit the cheetahs until
about round five that's when the
cheating
kick in a box all that stuff for trials
and getting sweaty out there but I also
wanna shut up to my man eat Bob's his
kind of fantastic show what man in arms
and he always tells me not to say this
or last word so I said now the best damn
destiny podcast you'd ever heard on
Friday well Bob man Eve artist you
already know not a MPC then it goes up
on annual podcast or later on that day
so yeah come check that out fantastic
show some good argument so you feel
about that hard lighten trouser oh yeah
if you want to hear how I really feel
about that highlight please go listen to
the last word cuz I go in on that easy
button gun that I can't stay if you want
to shoot aimlessly down corridors and
ricochet and make it a rave dance party
in the back you know that's all you hate
not it but oh yes I've been doing that
um little bit in a car crossing um I did
actually cooled off only because I was
playing I got caught up one of my old
games man I was talking to the other
short earlier it was a phantom doctrine
man I still love this game XCOM Cold War
spy espionage you and I'm saying it's
just really cool and it has a lot of
mechanics that XCOM doesn't have like
you have to like at it you have to plan
your escape you have to call in like a
vehicle a getaway vehicle before they
end it around before you do your thing
and you got like three terms and then it
could be compromised you could put on
disguises like infiltration it is money
yeah yeah the game is oh it's on it's on
xbox and I switched up the game is
amazing here's the problem the graphics
is in it could be you can you can be
fooled it might look like the Xbox it is
now it is literally a 360 game up rest
it's it's really you know what I'm gonna
blame this on King I'm gonna say that
they made this for the switch and ported
this was supposed to look good
is up for up raise the 4k on on the X I
was like that but oh you shot to score
lead a negate name of the game is called
phantom doctrine it came out I would say
too eager either go or die LP I have an
interview with the developer is a sore
spot for me because I know I've little
small Polish teammate they unfortunately
I think they went under creative forge
games I believe was that was it was a
cruel but um yeah you kinda cavers like
listen you said if Guardian said the
game is like hey y'all file you file for
that kid I see you borrow listen at the
end of the day if you love X column and
you love a mix with spy espionage Cold
War they even the investigations is
really cool man please check it out if
you're into that kind of thing so I'm
been doing that and then a lot of switch
game this week mess which coming in hot
they're playing that Marvel Ultimate
Alliance 3 with the Fantastic Four dlc
god Bingham in the bill whoo yes yes
[ __ ] company hi guess why it's
exclusive snitch it's exclusive you
can't get it nowhere but steady
attendance which I've been absolutely
loving it man check that out if you want
to get played with the first family when
I get that DLC going on and on yeah man
that's pretty much it for me on that
front now um I know we got the paint job
we're gonna try to blaze through this
real quick that Lord saw has lost his
voice so I don't have the sultry voice
of soft to do the names that he does so
I was going to do it Cognito style so
you gotta bear with me daddy fat stacks
this dude literally just sent me a
turtle man so let's do it start first
win arm we start a patreon members first
little cup of shoutouts can't God do my
fix all voice we wanna shout out to our
members of the realm again you support
us we really appreciate all is what we
get you know we cannot thank you guys
enough without you guys you give us
energy always make it fun in here so
let's start the shoutouts Lord debt
singer from the
realm you're saying UK salute Lord that
second you know saying then we got my
man Lord Jameson in the rim salute Lord
Jameson of course cat daddy fat stacks
in the building already given out coals
out here always giving up your remain
Lord
Taotao sweetie he's in the building of
course salute salute and of course the
cold bear a salute kobera Lord PD yours
this now though in the building one of
the stream team members we got our boy
family member oh yeah that's a lot of
journals yeah absolutely salute and man
I know definitely a man and wife he
definitely take care of those or slew to
Lord mostly Martinez you're a no what's
up Lord Michael Lugo monkey punch you
already know you know Z and of course
Lord chocolate died himself back salut
salut ahead of course
Sammy Prescott and of course and just
had a boy last week the Great War
himself now of the cognition team you
already know you know this ludus
Stillwell and us I can't pronounce his
name wrong stiff stiff sifl poetic X
initiative so salute to him and really
appreciate that and um Elia shallow
Levitch see I can't do it like swathes
office pool y'all go get the rough
version for me here we got for Germany
my brother Lord linchpin salute of
course we got log debts Oh Europe say
edit a chief assistant mom man today
salute Lord on deadly XVI and of course
you already know our brother destiny
brother gaming Forte no oh boy vagabond
oh in the building salut salut and of
course the number one switch hater
himself Lord State 6-6
if something here Smith Bob tried man a
child best I'll try to save soft voice
Mary I go get the rough version I a
smooth like so so we got dad and of
course we got my man Lauren meds saloon
or mess and of course the in separate
Ghost Lord Luke law by mid that's the
loot you brother really appreciate it
and uh novocaine in the building cream H
salute and HB 33 salute him and of
course to one of the best avatars in a
building slow-mo back slap and the
forever patron the man who always will
ride with us to the end Lord
whiskey you already know so those are
our patrons and then real quick we gotta
salute the members of the room all you
guys out there rocking the emotes all
the cool fun stuff y'all doing the
floors all that stuff so we run this
real quick we got a couple of new ones
so we're gonna salute that salute the
Lord de Ron Edwards man salute man
getting that Bronze level in you already
know Lord
Jameson hittin that joint button with
that Lord gold golden Lord you know I'm
saying kids smooth
I seen you earlier in the building you
know saying with the bronze north 288
281 Dean salute him and of course our
brother our podcast brother Lord
boomstick Excel double-barrel game and
salute brother and we got Lord hollow to
dinner and on
that's my man salute him my quill aka
bed fast bed Bed Stuy finest so Oh
what's up you've got a new one to just
join oh my god [ __ ] I got the shield up
for but give me the man give me the name
oh he joined the row the new recent Lord
to the road thank you brother man really
appreciate me I really appreciate the
support double dip and I appreciate them
they're pretty Smith said though for so
salt might want to read down was well he
was like he saw that because cog is
messing up the patient
yeah yeah we could add it got that one
pair together okay we're it's another
one Smitty Smith it's no disrespect to
car Oh Bush is early one-man show try my
best try my best
all right so we got there we got my boy
I already got dizzy you know I'm saying
should salute the head man from doing so
treatments and everything still here
still with us and of course Lord will me
hard man to look where were you man
that's not that's the prorate that's
what's up JD gamer cat daddy fat stack
Smitty Smurf I should call you baby boy
slander me you know we appreciate
everyone that supports this you know it
definitely helps run the podcast a lot
smoother but one thing I do want to
really think is the people who double
did because I like they don't have to do
that but you know they they they really
it just it means a loser like me in the
lot the fact I would have no up the
emojis you know get the
behind-the-scenes stuff that we throw up
and we have another just we have another
oh please no Scott please oh uh whoa
everyone welcome store Walker for to the
ELMO yeah we're gonna do it no doubt
without the graphic gunner that you
already know so salutely Smitty Smith's
with that Turner should die also smooth
get my man with the best tech reviews
all Lords of gaming that net my man
schools Tech Talk you already know and
of course double-dipping my man def
singer
we got tempers sun restored Hades blowin
Senado again gaming forte again pixel
bit gee mom made Jonathan be who miss we
missed last week because of the YouTube
notifications but he said he's but he
should be back on this week minutes Lou
Jonathan be one of the funniest in the
chat of course Lawrence
eight six six nine even though he
slandering me always game of by choice
you know we love game about choice kick
that my see hey you know you know you do
yeah everybody just like music
sleepy goblin the blue one filly Eagle
guy that's talking but she does so bless
his heart but this is why this is why
he's the boss right cuz he delegates say
you know you said this is for you solve
this is what you do when you articulate
the named you like you know shout out
two times B team you know you get into
it and you know just like I need a host
appreciation emotion upon you cause you
know I like two hours ago I told you
know what I would adore - do some hot
tea out of control so be touch I love so
so much some you're gonna run through
the the random winners this is we saved
your voice a little bit absolutely will
do that um so let's start off with this
$10 gift card gives you a moment to
shine salt I'm not at my best oh isn't
that good gift card giveaway it goes to
I'm still much appreciate that and your
car giveaway it goes to
Lord Michael lunch getting $10 bro yeah
yo so now let's go into this $20 gift
card giveaway go slow a new fairly new
page your Lord look Lord
oh it's epic those words Oh killing it
$20 are beautiful thank you so much for
the support brother alright now let's
get into this teespring giveaway mm-hmm
the winner of our teespring giveaway
we got beanies in there now too oh yeah
I got the babies as Scully's now let's
get that mm-hmm
I'm the winner of our teespring giveaway
gonna be crazy happy gonna be crazy
happy that's the sound of it now imagine
you can get down on that uh that
bleeding-edge tutorial man no doubt
though though yeah so I once again thank
you guys and thank you cog for covering
for me while my voice recover is um I
apologize that everyone for having been
behind so badly on patreon the stuff
it's just been a crazy a couple of
months but I think I'm caught up but I
still need Lord [ __ ] [ __ ] to get back
to me with his stuff with the steam
information and Lord seafood please get
back to me
yes info and then and everything started
the you till now should be covered then
I yeah but today I'll get I'll get to
you guys either today or tomorrow okay
and don't forget you guys where I'm
gonna Final Fantasy 7 giveaway on on yes
steak for my doing mm-hm yeah absolutely
absolutely addict is actually opened up
like 50 different accounts so he'd go
into himself
so look bad therefore apologies again I
know we went a little long and got a
little rough with it with it it's not a
smooth saw but we got to get to it but
anyway you there's enough of all that we
got all that what the Lord's been
playing and we got that pictures out of
the way but I want to finally know he's
been very patient he's been very patient
with us I apologize
what a start with long Capri this video
game system history his journey as a
writer and content creator and what led
him to becoming the host of the gamer
cats and co-hosting the Xbox Drive and
of course a cup of joe and they're dead
now so Capri let's start from the very
beginning what some of the first video
game systems you had one got you the
gaming you know a man like I remember
like it's so clear to me every I think
everybody has like that that one memory
of like when gaming starts for them and
for me it wasn't a console it was my dad
bringing home 386 PC like that played
like pac-man on it like that old like is
a crappy port of a crappy port it was
basically like the Atari port and cuz it
didn't have like dots a headlines play
right so we were playing on Doss like
we're playing Doss games back in like
1989 90 we're talk about lucky boards
now dude like mmm I am the keyboard wait
like 30 pounds had the computer had a
turbo button on it yeah you hit the
button it went from 12 we talk about
gigahertz dude we had 12 mega
variable you could see the difference
dude it was we so so we were like
obsessed but my family had four kids so
we needed to like you know produce we
were working from 8 years old Wow flyers
and stuff and so and and all the
neighbor kids had gang systems so like
why would my parents spend money I don't
know you could just ship us next door so
they got us a computer so so we're
playing you know just really really
basic dos games from from the early
goings but throughout the whole time we
had a couple neighbors across on the
block there was a neighbor across the
street worked for a telecoms company he
would always come over and fix it
whenever we'd screw it up and then I was
just as
about this earlier today I'm like there
was a guy down the street
his name was grant don't even know how
we even met grant salute the grant
sushella to grant every now and then
gram a grant is he opened the whole
world to games because Villiers every
now and then dad was ship us off to go
see grant he's got some games you just
got that random messages school your dad
says go to cram it was a good day when
dad said go see grant cuz you go see
grant and Grant had like this incredible
setup but he would he would send you
back home with like floppy disks like
nuns in the nuns of floppy disks like
doom and we had this game like really
Beamish and all like the police quest
and the space cash game like I you know
and I haven't thought about this in a
long time I keep thinking about like why
don't we first got our Xbox which comes
much much later but yeah like it was it
was we were ripping games off like crazy
copying games like disc after disc of
doom and doom tune of ones Wolfenstein
all those games but really just some
weird stuff - we had a not too many
people know that there was a Mega Man
game for PC was a tree bosses it was a
but terrible stuff like really bad like
and I just felt like back in those days
like if you were playing like a PC game
that was made for PC you were golden
those games were great
but if you're playing a PC game that was
actually made for console like not
enough was talked about Jake now yeah
but I remember dude I remember getting
like our first like gamepad like the
gravis gamepad with like the purple and
yellow and red buttons Wow didn't work
it was like free USB right let go like a
printer jack or something yes but it's
like maybe it worked maybe it worked for
certain games and like if it didn't you
you've restarted and like no SSD for
like reboot times you're sitting there
for forever so yeah it was supposed to
be like this
word processing computer but we sort of
we kept tweaking it like thanks to our
friends around the blog like G across
the street he was a super smart man
China he was very smart at this kind of
stuff down the road operation of people
which I mean talked about neighbor Matt
neighbor Matt is my best friend I don't
have a memory or I don't know him and we
had like a like our fence that divided
our backyards there was a gate in that
so our backyards were actually connected
well so we could have liking our fights
and everything but that also call up
Paddy's mad over later is not there yeah
phone nineteen seconds you're at the
next door we were that's what's up and
you just run over and play games like
that but they had they had the 486 we
have the 386 in the neighbor set of four
ago that did and a four times feed like
cd-rom okay tell us was crazy
wait are you guys gonna give out the
full game of Final Fantasy seven oh yeah
he's out of control
early day 82 Dalek Canadian our joint
had a terrible button and the monitor
had three colors you could damage
between an shoutout to a six-layer mm
objective the same way as so a complete
BGA super VGA like 16 colors oh my god
is good stuff that like you're like like
no death so neighbor met that was you go
to so again you know I was swimming he
had all the console so you should get
the PC space it like what was the
transition for a PC to console did you
kind of stay in that space at that age I
was in I was in the PC space for like
all the way through like half-life and
unreal and Rainbow six and Starcraft
Warcraft all that kind of stuff which
was all that actually is funny enough
cuz they introduced me to a lot of those
like the first time I saw Warcraft was
like what the heck is this and that was
all Matt but then they had everything
else they had Nintendo Super Nintendo
like that Sega I remember joking with
him like what is this PlayStation thing
was he
shapes yeah that's a good point that's a
very good boy continue that's not a real
system we should have a triangle box yo
that is fact yo PlayStation did change
the game in reference to just controller
naming conventions and inputs like they
were very bold and every good good do I
I was I was really I was in I was into
the PC gaming though man cuz I was all I
guess I was spending a lot of money on
it I've spent a couple hundred dollars
on my sound card on my surround sound
and everything I like five speakers and
a subwoofer at every day oh I spent
probably like my brothers and I would
all like pitching together spend like
$650 on a 3d FX graphics card playing
Tomb Raider 2 on that thing just like
and the perfect timing right you're like
12:30 our old boy Tomb Raider 2 comes
out you're like I want all the I want
800 by 600 resolution so I was I was
dead in in PC gaming like mold Knights
coming up I'm like will look at
half-life Brody playing early but I also
love gold mine yeah we would have we'd
have arguments man holy crap it was so
it was literally PC versus console her
for you died Wow so good what really cuz
I get unless you still stay PC what what
kind of made you kind of more transition
over to console more on a kind of a
full-time basis or you kind of I
mentioned that $650 for that graphics so
are you saying that the price
proposition of consoles war active is
that what we say it definitely it played
a it played a factor for sure yeah but
also like for like my parents were very
I don't know what it was but they just
they looked at that computer always that
computer was also games but mostly
homework yeah that's right a we're it
was mainly for that it was mainly for
work and everything but like we were on
those things going like pre-internet
like what are they called like those
little bulletin board systems and you
download like strategy guys just text
strategy guys from you guys enough like
that we
oh no he talking and talk right now
you understand me the sovereign is being
quiet right Mac is he saving his voice
but I don't know sovereign if not in his
head like he sobbed oh yeah that's right
it was it was a price and games too of
course like we knew that there wasn't
like we had we had we spent summers like
days Long's over at neighbor Matt's
house playing like forever like even
like starfox 64 we had two maps one of
them works good and he played that for a
day she was it was incredible and we
would rent we would on birthdays we
would rent the consoles to go to bus or
whatever down the street shop you had
the briefcase no you know what it is
yah guys y'all living a bubble right and
y'all think y'all only people doing it
until somebody tells you your same story
in a different skin yes yes he's just
telling you of my story and your story
is well in skin and he's giving you you
know Matt I didn't have Matt but I'm
pretty sure I had Calvin yeah but again
you know no Capri
one thing that I like to mention is the
people forget the power and the
importance of Blockbuster back then yeah
and those kind of stores where again if
you didn't have it right then and there
you could rent out those games you could
get it you can try out those console
that was a big part of gaming culture
back in the day and I'm glad your budget
we don't talk about that enough continue
yeah well in one of the games that
stands out for me like what for on the
Super Nintendo was I don't know if you
guys are heard of this it's called un
squadron Kevin yeah like this was a bit
like you don't like we didn't even have
we didn't even have like any of the the
magazines that were out back then we
just go to Blockbuster like this looks
sweet like it looks like planes and the
soundtrack on that thing is amazing and
then you're open like nobody played that
game you know okay well you I had it all
I had a three versions of it I had it
off Nintendo Sega and for turbo graphics
the best version of it is deter Bogra at
you no way yes was it the anyway cuz
it's um was an area 88 or something like
that it's like the enemy there's
basically yes I believe so
mmm that game is phenom
so yeah we always got a taste of that
man and then eventually my brother and I
we decided like okay we've been working
since we were eight years old with his
flyer route like yeah so why don't we
just pull up some money get a Dreamcast
and he goes the first that we're playing
like of course like Sonic and everything
else in the Japanese version of the game
so so you did the first console you guys
got that Dreamcast you said yes you what
you solid was excited about something
else you said you had the Marvel vs.
Capcom remember little arcade game Dance
Dance Revolution well and also like you
have to remember to you like back in the
day like modding your systems was
rampant yes right leg on Xbox that was
later to come ps1 ps2 neighbor Matt I
hope about to out a model give his last
savers salute amazing but he worked a
blockbuster a few years later so anybody
who worked I think it must have been the
same in the states as well where you got
ten free rentals a week so he would just
take games home Burnham beeches ups all
JD gave up on our super chat classic
computer gaming with I arson area
gave FAQ strategy guys let's go who in
the room was the first to have that one
megabit download speed no net with shout
out to the 14 for them 33 6 modems on
the AOL disk would you know about that
continued oh my god that brings me back
to I would just kick out completely this
takes me back a friend of mine Christian
he was the first one to have like over 1
megabit and we would sit there just
downloading random stuff come on man
just go you just likes to climb that was
such a big deal back day like you have
no idea when you're downloading mp3s
from Napster of three and a half
kilobits per second I remember cuz I
didn't know the whole like Metallica
thing I'm like but I wanted to listen to
Metallica you understand why I can't
because you know but why couldn't you
why can't you listen to it but
everything else you I remember I
discovered total psycho
I discovered Pantera by accident trying
to I was trying to download a u2 song
but every songs out to the viruses
people gave people and they all shot
dizzy with the Kazaa today let's go yeah
I want to be able predict cars I was
over there lob wire you definitely got a
virus effect so you had ed Norton
AntiVirus you was not gonna remember
when you used to look and be like oh
that's one song and it's like it's like
we were so dirty for that oh because we
won't date every pixel bit gee brother
fine I love superjet y'all remember when
it took two hours to copy a ps1 game
patience is a virtue y'all had that
problem I did it you know
shout out to my connect who shut up we
should have believed
as around I had a whole book yeah game
perhaps before game where you it's crazy
or shout out the shroom King that he
said remember that Morpheus never mafia
thing called magic calm yes five hundred
games all floppy
we went actually to see the magic comin
it was like this big hard drive they
really this thing you've attached to it
so you know when you you know and I'm
not gonna do directly like okay I can I
can copy stuff to this but he said no no
no no no copy he wanted confirmation
yeah the money he's about to put that on
right now it's gonna do what we wanted
to do what we heard in the streets down
the block oh my god the graphic over
here their friend who is studying
computer science who is his disk pusher
back in the night everybody had that
connect that one guy that could get you
to stuff so light like slusho Capri we
said he had his connection that I was
neighbor Matney but Matt was the connect
I need to know these details yeah he had
the PlayStation one but he got us into
the whole like oh so you can mod this
thing raisi Union you can MA and with
them
um with Dreamcast we did a disc you guys
like the boot up disc and want me to
kind of dig it out and then you could
get a swap yeah mm-hmm so yeah but we
never had a we did have a Playstation to
like years like until is like retro
you're trying to like go back in time so
after a Dreamcast it was it was Xbox
mm-hmm and then that's kind of like
weird on that that's where like it
connected like the PC origin yes so back
to like now it's Microsoft because
there's a hard drive and the scene you
load up with songs and a friend of mine
did the exact same thing he loaded his
game his hard drive up with 300 games or
something great yes so yeah man like
that was about the time this is stupid
story I was go but we were we were
gaming on like my parents old 27-inch TV
but it was like the furniture thing it
was like like they cut down a tree for
this hundred old tree and just like put
a TV into that into the base we talked
about the big back TVs that look like a
floor model that look like furniture
yeah house we talk about those that
weighed 600 pounds and Yemen you're not
you could you could actually like stand
on it you get all of you dad pop on it
and do like a white girl dance on it or
something
so the xbox was so technologically
advanced and we didn't understand they
always my parents didn't and we plug
this thing in and it was about that time
that this TV started to die but the TV
was like 30 years old this thing is
ancient so my parents thought that our
Xbox was killing it because of all the
[Music]
backward houses were filled with spools
of CDs yes
it was working five before the next
before important that black in a garbage
box we have to take up one of the spots
for the IRS yes yeah man yeah Xbox is a
good time and yeah but that was like
that was an expensive get that was
probably we probably walked up and it
wasn't even we didn't even have like a
best buy at the time we walked to the
grocery store and the grocery store had
like a photo lab in the back and that's
where we bought earlier my gameboy
yeah let me tell you about the old war
craft get the for our Warcraft game they
got interrupted by my parents picking up
the phone no no don't shoot damn mess up
that the clicky sound rangy old gothic
salute up the crest up for model Zenith
furniture yeah you had to go with the
decor the rest of the yes upstairs
Zenith was like a pity cool light that
was the joy back in the day man you had
nobody that Seaview only had a certain
number buttons so if like if your
channel is like channel 22 like for
cartoon driving oh I'll get a VCR
today's that the RF switch
if I could go back is having to turn my
channel over three or four well you know
you see us baby baby you guys talking
back on this you know how to do this how
to do that I'm just like that's for the
bushes man I gotta go to Cresto for
dinero for the arrow because he kind of
cover y'all and it's true he's like cog
your ad to Xena and he still had the
plastic or the cow see a grandma had the
flashy I can't even lie that was the
good living room
yeah they're good they're furniture see
dude that was that was a big thing the
liver was a thing back in the day yeah
it was absolutely very true bed this
gave me his wild and weak I could talk
to local free for hours oh we should do
it man either one day we shall go back
in the day before I was born
first thing I just pick up my phone
Twitter do this baby thing you could not
sit on that plastic that's a fact just
like a living room was just like a
museum
company when the company came you had to
be careful with all the porcelain the
ball I remember my my aunts not my
mother so much my aunt she used to keep
all the little porcelain um party favors
they give you for like baby showers and
stuff like yes keep that all not in a
cupboard somewhere but she put it on the
coffee table so you could not play
around a coffee you were done that was
pre decor so like I was I was you have
no shadow we got 30 chests out the rage
for again to the suture tips and tricks'
magazines yes Smitty Smith mm my aunt
had a room nobody could go in yes no
mother
classic living room stories of gamers
dealing with parents who had pristine
living rooms you could play it but up we
go yeah all the stuff is is beautiful uh
you know I love the chat is Rocco
wouldn't do much oh good we got we got
somebody gave me three in so I wanted
treasure she really into the content
creating part yeah you know like what
got you into content creating and then
of course you know I'm saying that the
podcasts that we know you for like we
the game or cats which I love I love
that it's really good one-on-one stories
I think you have a boy in six for Joe in
there and I missed that one and I think
all Benji got a really cool guest and
then you have some co-hosting obviously
with the xbox drive and then um with our
good friend Lord Nintendo guru cup of
joe a Nintendo so how did you transition
into podcasting I was I was obsessed
with podcast as soon as the man I hope
this isn't going too far back in time
let's go Matt when they had when they
still gonna feel still old I think there
was a time when podcast you had to plug
your iPod into your indoor computer to
download remember that like it was time
before but that wasn't when I was in a
podcast soon as podcast app just showed
up on its own I'm like what is this and
a friend of mine was really in a podcast
and he got me kind of going on the first
view which were non-gaming it was like
Adam Corolla Marc Maron a couple of them
ever man show and everything like yeah I
think his show was like the number-one
show for the longest time so I was
listening to those for awhile and I was
really enjoying them and then I was like
well I've got more time I could you know
as you do with podcast you start with
one and then it grows and then I
discovered I think like a lot of other
people all the IGN stuff like Beyond and
anything else and also in Canada
I don't know if you guys know too much
about like Victor Lucas was like
everywhere in Canada's on TV
EP daily like that's where like Canadian
kids with 11 video games they know
because he's our he's our lawyer guy
okay dude so we're watching watch him on
TV and he also has a podcast and I
remember him I was driving down for work
one time it was like probably 2014
something like that and remember him
talking to like like every if you buy
your own wall okay the other thing said
Victor is awesome continue he's just
he's just a extra champion of the
industry and he did this thing that a
lot of podcasters do a lot of like John
Greg um oh my goodness kind of funny
Greg Miller my goodness gracious oh good
there's what everything like Kevin Smith
they all do the same thing they say if
you want to do something just do it and
I remember listening to this podcast
like thinking like Victor Lukas is
talking directly to me
and I must do this like this is the
thing I wanted to do so you know I
basically kind of like put this thought
together my head early I'm gonna create
a blog it's gonna be called this silly
thing I'm just gonna start writing about
stuff mm-hmm
and it's funny how like the like the the
blogging world discovers each other I
don't really understand it but somebody
had found my blog and said hey I'd love
you to write for this site it was called
16-bit kings.com I wrote there for a
little bit and where things really turn
around for me was meeting Andrew
SEMATECH from we the nerdy and he's like
I wanted I want you to do some reviews I
would like you to do something like op
eds and things like that so and I
thought I was a good writer you know
like I think I could string a couple
sentences together again I can use words
that are more than three syllables
that's not that's a terrible don't do
that don't be used fancy words but one
day he's like would you like to come on
the podcast we the gamer cast it was
four people doing the news and pretty
typical kind of thing so I jumped on him
like I love this oh my it's way better
than writing I've got to sit there and
like figure out what to do with this ,
or whatever and I just love the podcast
and if that was really the start of it
that show kind of died after a couple
episodes I was hooked up to you know get
everybody
at the same week same time and
everything and I said could I just take
this podcast and kind of reformat it
because I like what Marc Maron is doing
with this thing and I remember he had a
show and I remember just seeing him like
the visual of him putting the cans on
getting in front of the mic and just
like talking to the mic I'm like that
looks awesome like I it was it was the
visual of him doing that and I'm like I
could do that I've been I've been
hooking up my VCR to my PC went back in
the day trying to capture and record
like Ace Ventura words that would launch
out when my computer started oh so I've
been messing around with audio for a
long time like waves do you in my today
I've been messing with stuff for a while
and yeah why the helmet I ripped off his
format completely seriously like ten
minutes of just intro here's what it was
that here's why I'm totally insane and
silly and then let's get into my chat
with this person and then I close out
and yeah like that's really what started
it Wow and Bob Bobby the Nintendo guru
was like I said before I think fifth or
sixth mmm person and anybody who started
a podcast yeah anybody who started one
especially for do it on your own
mm-hmm it's very discouraging yeah
that's a start nobody's listening why am
I even doing this like you know all
those things that come along and the
Bobby shows up and we have like the best
you talked about going down memory lane
covers talking about like his mom like
driving him down it he tell you about
the back of classic punch-out story he's
did he do oh I love his stories yes so
we just hit it off in the very end of
the episode he's like he's like you know
what Shawn I've really enjoyed our chat
and if anybody is listening I forget on
the show this is the most fun I've ever
had and it was just like even just
thinking about that memory like fills me
with joy and chills because that changed
everything yeah I was like somebody else
like a listener or again oh my god so
important I'm so glad you said that
because again you know even for the
Lords like you know adding knows like we
you know in the beginning we start this
thing and it's like you said you get
talking into that mic and no clips list
bigger the Jets empty we've all been
there
and you're you're bad with making
mistakes and it's like but when you get
that first or second person in that
shadow someone who responds say you're I
loved what you thought guys did or
whatever just that one person gives you
like to come back next week like what
episode like 170 20 or so traveler we
actually say like we started this part
you know the iron Lords podcast and
started covering everything me cotton
even sat down this is right right when
we brought solving King really let's
just act like those other ones never
happened this big what's funny the only
place you can find those is on
soundcloud because they're still there
like so then shoutout to the super chat
real quick i got rain dont the crash
from g4 for the final super chat my
grandma i had those basketballs all over
the house salute to that i remember
those
yes salute your stinger is loving lord
Capri he's saying wow sounds exactly
like how I moved to YouTube instead of
resurrecting for resurrecting my website
he is spot-on as far as the solo journey
yeah Alex James I'm here for free I love
it that's what's up so guess what a
touch back on that man like it you
really hit some real chords and a lot of
new content creators need to hear what
you said it's so important again that in
the beginning and then finally getting
that feedback from someone and getting
that confidence in your case it was the
trend of going little Bobby you don't
say having a tremendous chemistry and
then things you start to bubble from
there how did it patty move forward yeah
yeah it's funny because I look back on
those days and like we were just we were
so excited use and be making something
and there's like this silly like
innocence to it that I think people need
to like either if you get on with it and
go keep going remind yourself of that
every once in a while because there was
like this this you just wanted to make
something you weren't trying to perfect
anything you weren't trying to make it
for anybody you were just trying to do a
thing and there was quality in that
there was something that like there was
something so honest and true about that
that I think we all kind of like me to
remind ourselves I think I did that over
the over the winter yeah kind of like
November December like wait a minute who
am i what am I doing this for what is it
is it and as soon as you get back to the
like I love talking to people that's
where we the gamer cast just kind of
came back back weekly now and I just
love chatting with I just like meeting
people like this saying this this is
that's what it's about
the gamer cast is man love brother love
when I was at the end of the day it's
it's like you said that passion and it's
always good to go back like adequate
saying to me you go back to those old
when you listen out you say you're just
doing it for the love you deserve it
because I used to have like detailed
notes
I'm winging the questions I wanted to
ask and like what I want to say in the
thing so I pre type it out in their word
essentially just reading was so boring
but um but then it becomes a sickness
then becomes like okay I just want to do
this one thing or or then I start a show
with Bobby for a Nintendo yeah which was
which was created in a way both of us
kind of recognize we were doing podcast
and not everybody was doing nobody was
doing a real one-on-one kind of show
like tell me your origin story and I
just let me know about you if you're a
Nintendo was we started then the Wii U
days which was a terrible time to be
after you for everything you know like a
drone control
but I'm gonna tell you this right now on
Nintendo you still gotta pay five
hundred that was for Wii U yes yes did
that go down baby pop stars out just so
we get this whole quarantine thing the
kids are locked in here and it's minus
15 degrees outside because it's Canada
and so we're like what do we do we we
handed the kids over the Wii U we busted
it out we dusted it off and they're
loving it they're playing in the world
so we started the podcast in the middle
of like the worst times a Nintendo Wing
are they even gonna be able makes me
love that's true passion right there I
mean I was by the bomb Manny boxes did
the same thing with last word it was on
at the worst pour whatever II was
disgusted with destiny was cursing oh
sorry I was done with destiny there's
like it's [ __ ] and we like y'all we
still let his big let's see we could
talk about the fix if I could - heck yes
well that's that was the whole name of
the I mean it's not even making easy
show to say like if we're an intentional
of the game it's hard to say but yeah
thank you man we did that show for about
180 episodes we recently shut that one
down but the sickness that I was talking
about was I'm driving to work on a Skype
call with a friend of mine Dave Moore
and we'd been podcast we met through the
gamer cast and everything and we're like
you know what man like Xbox is in a real
dumps but I love my xbox I'm like he's
saying the same someone to ask you I'm
like how how am I supposed to have time
to do another show ever you already do
this and all the other stuff and then I
realized this this is the show us
talking on a Skype call this is a
podcast and and that's what we ended up
doing that the Xbox Drive started as I
was literally driving to work stop and
and yeah yeah like can you I was like
can you record this right now and he
said yes
and that was it I was on my I was on my
phone and I'm Rob minute you were
literally driving with you literally
driving that's that's what's up I was
just about to ask you what's the concept
behind the whole car driving X by I did
I did the whole pocket and did yo - late
that's was low yeah Wow with me actually
driving to work I was like well this
I've got time here like this how is that
connected video
honestly there's over there we've been
doing that show for about going on three
years and maybe two three like like
catastrophic like
connections but for the most part it's
been pretty decent man though and I know
ghosts it's something cultures well that
show for a little bit right you guys
yep posted for a little bit and then now
you have your boy oh Lord Ryan right
right he's on it yeah reffered yes
that's what's out there
I love Ryan man he's he's so he's so
sweet and he's just so he has this deep
knowledge of games that is and his
memory is incredible and he so that the
thing is like who drives a show and I
tried memories a young memory it's very
good yeah it's selective I drink too
many diet soda old men my brain as a way
to go into a house or something like
that I never forget the layout like high
school with the criminal money walking
and he does coke I have like a generic
photographic memory I know I know like
the tracks to certain songs like five
ten years later afterwards that's it
yeah everybody's bosworth different best
so you got that xbox drive going on cut
it and then just level ask what pockets
was it what was the transition to cup of
joe a Nintendo from we're a Nintendo so
we figured that when the switch launched
and we were a couple years into the
swing we fixed everything you know what
I mean by everything was everything was
done and and there's only so many topics
that you can go if we're a Nintendo Wii
true it's truly a good point oh it's
really from the start it probably should
have been kind of like a limited run
nunim podcast right and we just wanted
to Bobby
why don't you go back in and listen to
that party baton right now don't bend to
be baiting right there anyway so big
that you know the switch came in very
hot confluent look afraid you fixed it
ended oh there was no morning and God
lead to randint anymore cuz you fixed it
and now is cup of joe and Nintendo
records which is so much we just like we
cup of joe Nintendo is just a stripped
down podcast like there's there's really
like not even an intro it's not even
like hey I'm Bobby I'm the Nintendo guru
I'm like let's do that it's like the
concept is like as if we are and it's
terrible now if we were to meet in a
coffee shop Nintendo and of course we
can't go into a coffee shop right now
right click yes but yeah it's just like
the show cuts into like we're already
chatting mm I kinda just goes back to
the way to Bobby and I started chatting
from the very beginning was just like
the best conversations we have is when
they're not even structured like if
sometimes we'll talk about the games
were playing sometimes we won't
sometimes we'll talk about news
sometimes well like it's just like what
and it's in it's a half an hour to both
the cup of joe and the xbox drive are i
think polar opposite thing I've been
talking for longer than a half an hour
here no love them they're meant to like
fit into people's like commute space a
little short bursts that's of a shot
hole where guy thought crest up no room
above the realm one bad mother-- slope
spoken to Lord bronze a bronze Lord
bears illumine total crescent up in the
chat y'all make sure you throw them up
real quick you know say that's what's uh
steel stitches so faces were all why
hold on hold on don't make rest up for
slow-mo back lap 10 now solution shout
out to the aisle Lords - addict and
guest great show as usual Resident Evil
Three's campaign is longer than cogs
capping for Animal Crossing this $10
suture is worth more than a gear box
boat is on fire I don't acknowledge you
either so I don't I don't blame you for
not know why so he might have to get the
on the zone though he why I'd like to
give slow to ease I decided my cap it
went off the window of it I got
distracted I got distracted aware vite
vert obey you are wild tremendous
tremendous history last thing I want to
say before I ask some important
questions final questions is um you are
one in a few like I said has an amazing
partner you know saying and uh lady
Chelsea looks like she's also in the
game and I believe she does her own
podcast Oh Oh how's that go yes she just
says she just well she did breaking
Belle's with Bobby for a couple of days
oh yes and so she has a well it's funny
because she she does have played a lot
of animal crossing but you talked to
Bobby Bowden animal crossing and
suddenly you don't know anything about
animal crossing he's got he knows like
the birthdays for like the different
villagers told me how to shake them
trees multiple times to get more things
out I was watching his videos continue
well I'll tell you this one thing about
Chelsea that like she does her show her
podcast the parenting podcast lots about
video games the thing that like what you
always know that there's like that
moment right when things like you just
had to think I'll probably end up
marrying this person there's two there
was one very early on where I went over
to it I was gonna hang out with her
she's like bring over a movie and I'm
like what you want me to bring like like
a notebook or something she's like I
don't know bring over like Wolverine or
Resident Evil or yes marriage material
right okay so and then I show up and
she's on a condo she's on like the main
floor I slide in like instead of going
through the building just kind of like
walk in and she's sitting there playing
ocarina of time talking to some owl and
instead you've normally like when
somebody walks into your house you say
like hello yeah and she's just she just
gives me like the one second finger she
says you know like doesn't he's like
locked in on the screen she's playing
she's just a second no way oh my god
this is amazing
I'm I only I'm not even mad no this was
20th birthday party she threw me a she
threw me a Mario themed birthdays
I party like that yeah she's she got my
3ds she yeah man she we've got it was
her idea
my set up I can't believe I didn't tell
you guys about this our set up on the
other side of this room two TVs we each
have our own set up like she can play a
game I can play a game we play like
Borderlands together side by side we
don't do any split-screen stuff
no and that was all her idea if we had a
wall big enough we would have three TVs
because we needed one for the middle to
watch actually like TV while we plug in
you know you settle for two mm-hmm yo
that is true but it's it's so cool to
like I said when you have a spouse tat
like that King was saying I just that
shares your passion you know I'm saying
it's not like it's a burden and I love
what you said like you know she's like
hold on one second we about to do they
like technically that's good another
person who may not be into gaming you
respected where my passion was so you
like you don't feel that explain the
Michael yeah Michael mercy
mmm Lord Michael mercy definitely hit
the science of that whole chemistry like
when you walked into the house that it
didn't started before you even got to
the house cuz the movie that she was
bringing you thought it was gonna be
some typical crap like the notebook and
you know nothing actually like to know
oh but she said something that was in
your vein mm-hmm you know that's what's
up and then we get there she's really
you breaking the barriers of of what my
expectations was and then looking at
your setup mm-hmm you know you can't
have an elaborate setup like that
without the level of love and trust this
in that you know yeah say that you'll do
your thing I'm you know and don't
compromise yourself and that's where you
grow and you know that's when times
passes you don't even know time pass
you're living it and you know Lord
Michael mercy encapsulated it so
perfectly because you know it's a lot of
times we have different guests on the
show and everybody is special in their
own right
you know I will truly remember all this
whole journey with you just prefer this
porcius portion is class in the earlier
portion but the fact that just sitting
here it with this joy that's why you
look so you shut out the Dalal HD she's
a husband and I are the same we could
not share on gaming spaces we have about
eight consoles it's kind of ridiculous
everyone say to the chat that's a keeper
Lord complete as a wife she's a keeper
she take you seriously to men like you'd
think that we'd be playing Animal
Crossing together she's like I don't
want you messing up my island tremendous
gaming history tremendous bear gaming
marriage knows this so I got to ask the
question that we asked all the Lords of
the realm you them saying so the first
set is I need Lord Caprice top five
video games or franchises of all time
okay it'll be different every day I
think like a lot of people let's get it
okay Starcraft
mhmmm Dragon Age half-life's got to be
in there flies mm-hmm
let's see you know what and throw some
love to call it duty what yeah listen
let me let me explain like people to
understand I had this conversation
without the undead and yeah but um like
as far as infinity what I like what
infinity war came in like the initial
the Zampella those first two like oh
that writ
low-key that's what got me to stop
playing Halo cuz halo prior to that
ruled as far as my multi play experience
but when I saw those on consoles it was
just wow next look even the campaign's
know how it was like a
a badge of achievement - - finished call
of duty on veteran veteran even though
the random endlessly spawning enemies if
you didn't move forward flame like the
hostage situation was in modern warfare
the original one there was a blame in
the end like they hadn't beaten under
like two minutes or something crazy like
that yes there's like there's hits and
misses with that series but I mean
that's what everybody strives for in
terms of like feel and look at
everything and do like on the 360 Call
of Duty 2 was just like yes what do you
know you know as of May when you saw
breathing out of the enemy I was like do
that difficulty tremendous five and now
the new question we asked all right
favorite console of all time and why and
why any gentleman somebody somebody said
360 a couple weeks ago and I was like
damn that actually might be hit that
actually might need the one I think it
might be the 360 although I am loving
like my I love this generation because I
can play like you know like a newbie
disingenuous to say like oh the Super
Nintendo was my favorite like I didn't
even own it like I got it and they're
like I didn't own it and I didn't know
like until now like when kind of gone
back in time and then bottom at garage
sales and whatnot so yeah I don't know
it's I feel like it should probably be
limited to one that I actually owned
when it was a thing know like 60 you
didn't 360 I did but I don't let me stop
your joy brother don't let me stop you
love it I love it
tough question ask really you are the
first and you go oh hold you to it
x-bar right what is your goal of all the
time
I'll hold you to it no matter what the
day on somebody if somebody asked me my
favorite game or console on a day it's
like it's gonna change a lot of people
like wouldn't agree with this but mine
was the n64 mmm I remember that's where
I first like really sat down and played
Zelda cuz I played Zelda for like the
NES and stuff but I never really played
it because I was too young to really
comprehend hmm when I played a month in
but like the n64 besides that maybe the
ps1 because I played my first Final
Fantasy yeah how to that I'm torn detain
that's a neo genome turbo graphics and I
never see those cops yeah well a lot of
people didn't see me oh gee oh yeah a
lot of them financially cos I would
probably have to say Neo Geo because at
the time that's when arcade graphics was
really whatever you you we have
purchased it it was exactly the same in
the house and I remember purchasing a
cartridge I did I remember it was to do
at that moment mm-hmm side the store and
they had fatal fury mmm I said you know
let me get the fatal fury because they
you know add it for me and I want copy
because they will only get like two
copies and then one copy was there and I
said okay cool how much is that he said
two hundred and sixty-five something
yeah yeah I was like now at the same
point is two hundred and fifty seven
dollars is that with or without my
kidney say yes mean cogs hate came in I
know the story continued yeah I didn't
know I didn't know cog like the seething
hate for me because prior to this
purchase right I didn't know this
purchase was gonna be the formulation of
my demand
yes right so prior to the purchase God
took his is equivalent to 200 you know
what was there a big Genesis the first
ain't make megabit cartridge
which writer for the Genesis Sony much
striker now cada did not know prior to
that I was always in the arcade I sat
down in one house over the joy his eyes
because he said I got you brother
for us it's one of those day we had this
rule like it's a stupid rule but I don't
know why we had what it was it was a
personal thing like if you bought that
new game you brought the friends over
right you let your friends try the game
right you let them try it but this is
unspoken role I don't finish my day one
purchase in my face like like you can't
be do like you can't come over and we
just doing this new experience and then
you get it and beat it in front of me
now you leave and my game was beyond its
ear it's like he did it like Strider was
a thing right understand it was the fur
from graphical fidelity for Genesis it
was the first eight megabit close to
arcade perfect right so we come home we
staying up all me bugging out and then
King and I see the credits going up on
my and I'm like my guy like you worry
all right
but you gotta hold it in so when is it
when he got to me
let me try let me let me see if I can
get it a little revenge kick for for
ruining my bow but I got to get it was
classic that's classic
anyway those silly stories of maggoty we
got to show to get into a lot of stuff
tremendous history lore Capri I'm
holding you tonight Xbox one when you
come back - I'm holding your dad I need
some Dragon Age man what can I say
though they all been shout - one bad
mother-- with the stupid Safa who want
to get that we got old gamers y'all okay
so let's do I got you one bad mother--
he's the new member of the round file
super chat ILP gaming history sessions a
Sunday therapy for us old gamers
nostalgia is a helluva drug salute buffs
brothers you know that is facts you
already know so we go get into we got
the pole and all this good stuff
elastic opponents aren't into people
have spoken
let's get the question with the initial
announcements of project s cloud xbox
backward compatibility and game pass
ultimate being staple features moving
forward with the next generation which
of these features do you think is most
important for the series x the winner of
the 4-way ILP vote with 59% of the vote
is oh my god King is the lettuce Xbox
exclusives day and date game pass is the
best deal in gaming that is the winners
mm-hmm i bill kid would be happy with
this result covenant at second place
with 23% of the vote was Project X cloud
Wow
so we'll hit mark its traditional Xbox
consoles will never be able to reach
coming in at third 10% of the vote was
Xbox back compact it's critical to keep
in generations of the Xbox ecosystem
unified and in last place seven percent
of the vote was I don't care
yeah and got that energy for that VR and
AR with the hollow leg - all who
participated in the poll Lord addict do
you agree with the people with game pass
no delvis or like we got some topics to
get into the first topic is up lord king
grabbed this up with the quickness soul
or kid man um I believe what's the
Dominus was making his words today let's
talk about it what's going on the world
film all right so um so pretty much um
you know we had Phil he was all looks
like he was making around he was on two
shows um one I believe was IGN unlock
fantastic interview but let me tell you
man Ryan McCaffrey I know somebody Xbox
committee that gives him a little bit of
mess but this man is always privy to
some of the best interviews it's far as
far as far as experts in general
great great interviewer generation oh
that's one of my fate what he did the
generations of xbox he had Phil he had
my man you know said yet all the
generations man Peter Peter more yet a
shame is a mess
oh my god like just to hear the stories
and then it was cool to have you know
Phil as the young new kid that has taken
their the rings there you never say it
so now you know phil has come back he
was on you know on unlock he had a lot
to say and you know the the consensus
seem to be very confident and people
seem pleased so lord King you know what
did you get from now no this was your
topic and you wanted to bring it to the
realm okay well alright so you know look
at me we'll hit hit hit us in the south
did you check this out your boys in the
bag right and oh I don't like you guys
out here right now um that running
around talking boy your new field could
do it shut up because I would wanna
island by myself
and I must say again by myself there's a
lot of you diehard had firm belief from
even was they call it
what's DJ from Transformers the light
our darkest hour like even what it was
those bulbs
keg was like that that's why May he's
the guy I'm telling you yeah because a
lot of you guys are out here claiming
you know yeah yeah no no no you were
saying let's take a wait-and-see you
diehard dudes and you know I'm looking
right into your soul right now because I
know the truth your receipts are not
your receipts are fabricated mines is
authentic right and I'm gonna tell you
why and you already know the story you
know talk to him I didn't care about
t-shirts being given out I didn't care
about anything that was going on in the
background my conversation with him was
deceit war was in the soul of man
because my company want my company but
my my the company I chose to love my
xbox that I chose to love was on the
brink yeah
do you understand how close they were to
being dissolved and that was it Mountain
shout-out to Terry Myerson there was a
structure that was in place that was
destroying the fabric of the company and
in the games that I loved there probably
will never show up again you know type
of thing and I was on that part I was
like man they really fumbled this joint
and you know the glory days of the 360
the fun you know the connecting TVs and
stuff like that yeah there was this
little shining star in the corner and
talk to girls Spencer but this is before
he got Dominus oh this is Phil spenfree
dominus talk and fest you see this dis
says fan fest this for the fans mm-hmm
facts if you got a Sony a scarf please
know what for the wave that is continued
oh I got a chance to meet him and I got
a chance to look at his eyes and ask him
you know a very important question and
he answered the question I mean honestly
and truthfully look me straight in the
face grab my hand and said you know how
did you like the show mmm and I said you
really want the real answer
mmm-hmm definitely his foe Spencer is
definitely one of those people where he
he wants the real answer he might not
like it he knows he might not like it
but he'll respect you gotta respect the
transparency you wanna be true
mm-hmm so he gave me the truth and I
knew that moment right this I said this
guy is going to bring back that good old
feeling mm-hmm a lot of young guys
laughter cloud y'all you guys laughed at
his vision of where Xbox
nobody cares about backwards
compatibility games I have to give it
off to King because you know we might
bicker around and joke around just a
little bit of these sessions but
everyone on this show at one point of
time has won at this man overfills yeah
we've had a couple years everyone - came
on over our table has definitely at one
point questioned or had an issue right I
mean we have conversations on this show
where it's like now I know you know Phil
might not be that dude it was more so
like he's got a lot to prove right
because of what's going on against him
you know I'm saying hold on one sec I
just gotta get four it's a shot put the
crescent Forte follow super chat sorry
for being late but I was reading at an
absurd that time last night shout out to
the Lord for making my quarantine a
better
hashtag three I'm rating above a salute
that you can make people and I knew what
was that I know I see myself out of the
room you don't have to tell so kick back
to what you were saying you know
obviously like we got with giving it up
to you we are bending the knee to King
before the vision you know I'm saying
seen it man is denied as we're wearing
dominance mode right we're Maximus down
and he's in do you did you see the level
of confidence that he was exerting do
you know what that man knows he gots a
secret for you secret for you interview
I don't believe in a secret sauce yes he
said that you know
I don't I don't subscribe to that what's
on the papers on the paper you mean he
said he said like a year ago like you
know when people kept asking hardware
hardware he's like he's like well if the
harbor is gonna be good let's talk about
the games first yeah so he built the
company he got developers together he
got he got it he got a squad he got a
team behind them and I see a level of
confidence you see it chuckling mmm see
the smile you see energies different and
he's he's different there's no question
reacts a very important question
mmm-hmm I did not he saw you know Sony's
Roboto
see feel really good I like a week is
with a couple of days that's the left to
the side because he knows no matter what
they do what they come with you go get
this work because we gotta put them
together put them together he's rockin
right now he's at his back okay both
emojis going right now Cathy how did you
saw that he was in his bag and he knows
they came because they can't reach past
meeting with their really blue stick
right there they took the rocky boots
they out of boosted up today they can't
catch the toe that establish yes not a
positive question
she was looking for mm-hmm not who we
know that PlayStation is you know doing
the economy thing yeah and you know
what's left is for price you know he hit
him to you gonna get that price up over
here to here
Brooke what I'm pretty sure he did
mention what I want to bring thou is he
did mention multiple times that he he
wanted to state we are flexible on the
price he like he was an act agile agile
was the word could do right now we are
at the point where it seemed like he was
saying we're gonna react to the price
not say a price right so so okay now
when he said this part this is the part
I want this is my part okay cuz
everybody got the only thing come from
the interview or what he said well what
do you have a timeframe when I'm say
maybe June maybe July I told you guys
that he's going to hold it
he's going to for Sony his listen I came
into the chat today mm-hm
playing back-to-back you know shutout I
was giving him that dead to Canada oh we
heard you Drake a true in pregame yes
waited for days you weary I told you
that I told you before he was meek mill
he's trying to smoke y'all have you
reveal your head because he knows when
you say that price and that joint is a
stone mmm because death blow because if
you don't meet you and privacy don't be
like 10 15 dollars more he's coming for
your throat and your thought Oh Phil is
so nice he shake hands I don't see no
more those people that was in that
picture with my man my man is cheap the
cheese stands alone
so he's on he's doing the promo talk
yeah he's on a run is
no question he is dead little run and
the other dudes get out the Spartan King
oh you're just getting information on
something that is probably fabricated oh
well listen we gotta get out of here we
go by Smitty Smith Phil Dominus I know
pretty good and we got our situation
under control unlike other people the
book ax
Oh put the crest oh sure we got rangy
forward to follow to a child king salut
send them haters to the Omega sanction I
don't know what that is me how you feel
fanboy ISM right now you're king of the
world so kid yes we got to get these
boys have you got to get little Capri
together by feeling to another one we
got a $2.00 super track from pizza bit
gee I came here to hear King get in his
back oh my god they would continue King
they clearly would hear you continue
preaching continue and I noticed
remember I noticed BJ know if it was bad
for the PlayStation nation mmm my
timeline didn't get no ax I notice it
was bad for when I'll be there for you
Christopher I love that you had to put
it in color
go ahead go for it yeah he said two
dollars so to chat gonna get at it we
got a two dollar super Jeff from
Christopher art ps5 got y'all got y'all
this scared question mark question mark
last day we got Jim walk Lewis with the
2000 which have following every ps5
comes with a fire extinguisher
oh my god your pettiness real quick we
got to get us to the rest of the round
right the round tip in on this interview
that's why you put laughs my
but off because you know as a joke I
just want to end off on this point good
days is coming mmm
for some for others
oh talking I was walking I had that big
bossy walking energy was popping you had
you know what it is right when you walk
wake up a beast right you know was
afraid that he was gonna turn around and
gaze at you swatting at his back mm-hmm
now you're about to be stomped out y'all
know y'all at the brain and the level of
recovery is very very scarce like you
might not make it out of this one
like super booms day is back there I did
this for a reason visual you see he's
holding in his hand
your thoughts funny but super thought he
could be beaten can we kill of the
analogy thing can they get the system
out first they make a claim victims the
heat issues we will get to that hold on
before we move with this sugar free
violence super chest Smitty Smith I got
Chris kid like he playing a real-life
game of resident evil 3
I am his nemesis the book of X we gotta
get this girl because we gotta go we've
gotta get the rum Lord Capri obviously
we have the the Phil Spencer interview
obviously King feels away about his you
know how he took the interview I wonder
what was your take what did you get more
your impressions from this interview
I love Kings take man finally finally we
have we have this and it's it's a you
know you guys have talked about this in
the past before but it is amazing yeah
how quickly the narrative can change
like oh well power matters like I'm
sorry I had to go through all the
garbage to start out the II started the
console generation to go actually this
one does at full 1080
and and everybody knows back then that
the differences were minor but it was
made out to be this giant they know this
is our time and so I loved I love the
interview I love the I kept waiting for
because because Ryan has a way and I
think Phil even to like I think he is he
gets excited about what he's what he's
got for us
yes and I was waiting for him to like
say something that just maybe would slip
because he's just writing good so good
so good I was waiting for like a control
type of slip though but like that was
once-in-a-lifetime kind of thing that
was the control slip about kind of
revealing some real quick I give it
right back to you Sean shout-out to
stage six six nine Wi-Fi lights of a
chat yeah so scared that Sony had to
push the last of us to back because they
got no get oh my god I would like to see
how many ponies are flip back to Xbox
who did that for you he's in here
repping the bosses are hiding in the
[ __ ] Capri so oh you look very
confident very involved in you know
about what any other points you got from
the interview that day that stood out to
you it's just that it's I feel like if
you've been in the Xbox land for the
last five or six years that you know
exactly what this is there's not gonna
be any surprises this time anybody who
upgraded from like a one or an ask to
annex like we'd know what this what this
transition is gonna be like for us the
games are gonna look better is gonna be
faster and all these things I've said
right from the start of the Xbox one X
that not actually what that's not an
Xbox one like I'm looking at point I'm
touching arena this is not the same
console is totally it's different
insides it's different cooling system is
different Ram it's like it's it's by
name and Xbox one so I feel like the
transition is gonna be exactly the same
thing you put the same disk in those
things are gonna work they're gonna be
enhanced for the series X so a lot of it
is like we get news but we're like we
kind of knew that already like the smart
delivery we're like what didn't we know
that or anybody like we didn't it just
makes sense
and that's the comfort that I have where
I think a lot of the the benefit of the
doubt is being extended into so Neil and
I'm not sure aside from like why why is
that but at the same time I'll save this
too this is maybe we're a little bit
different I will say and I've said the
entire generation that I play all like
my third party games my cross-platform
use they're on my xbox right the
PlayStation 4 has such a library of
exclusives yes that it's actually worth
it just to have the exclusive I only
play these gooses on my ps4 and it's
totally worth it no no we are the same
and that fact that I pull it out every
two to three years with all invited
whenever they dropped a triple a bang is
I am at their doorstep bite of a new
Lord addict your thoughts on feels field
ominous talk okay you know we bought
that we bought the Hat five-o is already
Microsoft didn't have they boots Saudis
through this if you made it worse messy
to say yo see you next week no we got
that is the next topic we could get into
that but let's focus on Phil's message
please at the end of the day Phil
Spencer he's gotten to the point where I
feel like I feel like he when he
originally took over the Xbox he was
like look we lost this whole generations
in our they know we could do right but
what we could do is we can make sure
this will happen he was literally having
his people just take the water out of
the ship trying to make sure it didn't
seek while he was having the series X
being built at the other end of the pond
and he's like I just need this to make
it to that Greg and then I can get him
back well you like you say you could see
his his vision I think we're even Ryan
mentioned it from console design right
and going from the Xbox one kind of like
the the bulkier you know almost a VCR
you know they look I got I got a I got a
pathway I need to work on service
hardware services then games right we
got the hardware with the Xbox one X we
got the services of game pass/no you
know X cloud now we're on the games part
like he's literally done everything this
man has ever said he's done addict did
you catch the part when he kind of
talked about when you talk about what
you're talking about but when he came in
about changing the morale he almost he
would never say it but he almost Loki
took shots at the previous regime that
the thing about yeah because he said
like the the confidence the morale that
the teams were so beaten down that they
weren't being listened to
right and then he came in and he had his
goal was to kind of uplift them once he
now has the role did you catch that part
as well yeah you know what I like about
this podcast is just you know we've
we've been seeing it throughout this
past couple months when he does
interviews but this particular podcast
mmm he was in his bag everything he said
he was just like it was funny is he was
trying the PR talk and ride was trying
to cut through that I was the PS 5 SSD
can outrun you find out super chat from
JD gamer rules of life big Wow look big
bag take a little bit that's a king line
Wow your bear unless you're willing to
get my mouth oh yeah PS fans will still
be talking last gen wins in 2030 Wow
yo shout out the optimist cold for King
you want to get
kick 25 that's the cold right there i
king happy birthday hope y'all make the
most of it given the current situation -
everyone knows great shows own love much
love and optimist cold the homie man
absolutely a guy hey what you say so
you were really feeling good about that
those are your stand-up walks I felt
like when it comes to this when it comes
to what's going on the more that they
come out and they're open you could tell
that they're that I love how he's
transparent but a lot of people want to
include myself sometimes we can't we
can't take transparency right we want
people to be transparent and present
like why we here and lie to you
low-key and then and then say we didn't
lie technically six seven months later
we haven't any next [ __ ] games is all
gonna be cross-gen and but you know
we're gonna make sure that the people
with the series X gets what they paid
for runs just where I could have no
games made for that you know I respect
that at the other day you know I I still
have my beliefs on that right but at
least I have someone that's wanting to
be transparent raping all [ __ ] for facts
I definitely agree with you on that man
big big time skid Lord saw he's been
saving his voice for the topic so we got
to let him unleash right now Laura
sobbing what did you feel about the
indominus I think what really struck me
when I was like okay is when Brian asked
him about um what like did did the
situation that's happening right now did
that throw like all their mind into
disarray how does he feel about how he's
gonna roll out the red messaging and
whether it's more console stuff and then
you know Phil said yeah I mean we still
have to talk about the UI and stuff like
that and stuff that we talked about but
I wanted to get all that stuff out of
the way because the truth of the matter
is if I look at the rest of the year
isn't a single show that we would that
we're doing or would do and we're we're
announcing something new and I was I'm
yeah he said he said it would have been
greedy they had to look at that every
show there's always something new a new
game or some new to talk about out
pretty pretty impressive I did catch
that okay you didn't say that for all
while a now is everything's changed he
doesn't have any everything's been
canceled if you think about it this year
like just this year alone obviously a
lot of these games is coming out to
multiply because of previous publishing
bills but what I want people to really
focus on isn't necessarily you know the
game being a multi play it's the studio
making the game this validates the kind
of concert that can make for Microsoft
in the future off the games they're
making now but no fan of Catoosa doesn't
it seem doesn't it seem like and they
talked about this to where Phil is
finally like is that the CEO level he's
at that level saying yeah we now have
the full might of Microsoft yes like
this fun was like guess I'm always he
always he always manages to me to make
sure that he says yeah I talked to Satya
yeah let it let it be known and he liked
my xbox get active that may be your
greatest great ok nice on it you're on I
gotta give you two you're onto something
right now because you're right that is
the most underrated Phil Spencer
accomplishment because again prior
regimes they we it's been on record
like you said like a brief it was Xbox
was viewed as a side project it's this
thing that could possibly make Microsoft
us the big Microsoft money but we you
know we'll see for him to get at the
table to have Sasha having them taking
it seriously and then having the funding
right and the support to go get studio
to do it because I think one of his
India say in this interview about and
prayer prior interviews he said like if
we're gonna do this with gaming under my
watch we have to do it for we have to go
all in and that's a great point
I wondered you know another thing that
he said that I think a lot of people
overlooked
mmm-hmm he referred to his game like you
know the Microsoft games coming to other
platforms like this which we haven't
been very good at like message oh he
low-key that's what I was like he was
like don't expect
my snitch gag day he's like I don't like
that conversation yeah I don't I don't
like the assumption that everything that
we do is going there like yeah we had
some choice games it because of the type
of games or whatever if it
he said don't yeah I like the kid he was
almost kind of mad at he's kind of mad
after he caught the energy right it was
almost like I don't want to confuse what
so that every time a new Xbox game comes
out you have to wonder if it's coming to
switching ah he said yeah I ain't liking
that like their energy is different now
with that said I don't like the the
communication and messaging we've had
towards that right I want it to be a
paint like I'm gonna say right now that
you know a lot of people he'll play to
is gonna be multi play nothing this
multi played it's all PC and Xbox well
yeah
cuz he used it when he needed it I love
that's the thing I love about it the
best was he went everywhere else when he
needed it and now he doesn't need it
I think that's tweaks to the combat to
me is what that speaks to is the
confidence like you could if he was like
if you use worried about the messaging
he could create a clear message about
what games are gonna be where it's the
confidence that you don't need to be put
into the games on PC and Xbox and that's
it yeah I love that unstable yes balance
and just the thing is he's good
Jesus please spread the word okay he's
bringing everybody back down to earth
and saying he's been very clear said
this multiple times I'm happy with the
diversity of our of our of our portfolio
right now what that means is what that
means is that you're gonna get a lot of
new stuff it doesn't look like God or it
doesn't look like goes coochie MA so you
know that arguments gonna happen there
regardless of how much new stuff comes
out of pipeline and I hope that it's all
great
right Allah does not if there aren't
comparable titles to those titles right
he's gonna get the side-eye from a lot
of people and it's just there's still a
lot there's still more to do let's get
to it she's gonna be there I don't think
Sony could touch the diversity but
that's not Sony's plan right so plan is
to while you dirty parts and action
games let me interrupt you real quick on
that statement I feel like a lot of the
fans of PlayStation gave them that for
that like they're like I like
PlayStation cuz the diverse they had
gains for me I heard that all the time
throughout the years so like Microsoft
really toned like you know they're
toning down you know if you think about
it I think I personally think they're
more diverse than Sony now only dude you
do just about anything
we know that Sony still a force to be
reckoned with maybe Kings a little bit
more thinking you know the one sided
thing but you know obviously they still
got the God of War twos you know they
got there was diversity really a thing
was that even a conversation time where
like every time we saw a PlayStation 4
game it was like over the shoulder
action or action-adventure over the
shoulder narrative-driven like it was
like yeah it all look the same it right
that's necessarily what people were
talking about they're talking about you
know how convenient to forget about it
you know you got the the Gravity Rush is
the persona 5 of course of course you
know the Yakuza is but which is I you're
on it because the majority of those
games are on Xbox now but wait
is no because if it blew up with my
system I thought oh don't be that moment
- from JD JD gamer though didn't just
get a seat at the table he managed to
get the old example xbox Oh
blocking regimen down the future is
bright
oh regime is down ok I get it JD gamer
Philo stupid shot again the battle is oh
my god the battle is over it was over
when Sony showed up with a 9.2 teraflop
system boosted to 10 point 3 then
sidestepped the power narrative talking
about SSDs it's over according to oh
let's see again oh he coming from me
father knock hog the PlayStation fan
boys need though these hands they was
talking the whole time I'm gonna go
ghost on the show oh you messed up
jockeys let you got take off at MLB - oh
boy a VR listen because he gonna be
playing it all in it until 2021 when I
place a sink don't get it
you know I think you know I never really
played Yonkers I really enjoyed
blood-borne splashback Iowa what the
best games this generation
spider-man's average nice off that I
don't really care about it might be the
show's a multi-platinum behold all shout
at the gene though I got he's onto
something because that's a strong
line-up shy job to be giving me the
fraud alert mr. [ __ ] Sonia's fawning -
you got a $5 super chat
JT game the Tower of Power and game the
game he'll play to put Xbox foot on
Saudis neck that's why they silent hell
plate is scary really but you know what
will give you will give you that show
back I want y'all to understand one
thing right ok so a lot of the guys here
are very diverse you not is really he
plays a lot of PlayStation 4 okay and
he's gonna be playing this PlayStation 4
with the Final Fantasy a cog is right
now pcmasterrace but he's really you
know switch gang and you know sovereign
he dips and dabs and everything you know
I'm this one over here with the field
ominous Maximus Spencer talk if any
y'all got the slam there please come our
way I will take it I've been faking it
the whole time I don't want you ever
think that says this is an Xbox central
park no I'm the only one out if you look
I am the only one without the flag on
alright I just want you to understand
one thing so when yo when you don't want
to go at the team not them as me when
the hate come down and you say oh they
know is me without that leap of faith
there's no leap of glory tell me I'm not
smelling these roses I'm smelling
I put you see the vigil I told you I'm a
visual do you see the skull over mine
and I'm telling you
doomsday is back there for oh let me get
my bars off look like you know I joke
around if I put the top five my games
this generation let me say Microsoft
ain't on that five in three of those or
Sony games no it is but all I'm saying
yeah it's from a standpoint now hmm I
got nothing to say about PlayStation we
in we in April one of the marketing team
salute it's like eight nine let me give
up
look the interview was outstanding you
know I'm saying um fills in his bag the
confidence was there the swag was there
they're doing all the right moves
you know I'm say it's not even not
taking nothing away from you like I get
it Xbox nation I feel it I see the
energy I know what shout on it's the
beating up kids that are finally like
yeah we're bullying the bully I get it
all I'm saying is you know I'm saying
that the things that I took about it was
definitely his leadership definitely
taking over and also huge you know say
and just the transparency that that is
what I give yatta most because they're
being transparent whereas Sony is not as
much we don't know what's going on you
know Sam so I get that I love how he was
transparent about the removal of
features you know I'm saying about the
UM the the digital optical the IR blasts
how he already had to plan and they
actually they were looking at the
numbers who actually uses the stuff
right and he was like look you know
we're not gonna we're gonna make some
people upset but we have to look at oh
and if that means bring all that stuff
helps bring the cost down then great
only we got this fire on a super chair
you want to get that one clutch man yeah
we gotta find out a super chart from
clutch man ps4 can't take out a built-in
camera
if those Spencer said designing
peripherals into the UI bear on the
system Xbox series X a console built
from one thing games no doubt and the
thing I want to say to another thing
that a lot of thing I caught solve
logical he was very upset
Ryan asked him some good questions about
games that didn't
blow the way they shine why was
fantastic he asked him about like sunset
he asked him and Phil mentioned rise and
sunset overdrive and he he could tell
saw he was not happy that those games
didn't do it that he called it the noise
of the peas did you catch that and he
basically was saying how though I wanted
me but resolution gate so to speak right
resolutions long overshadowed did it's a
bit again of those title did you notice
how he kind of took a jab at Sony cuz
when they're like you know the
competition you know they had these
amazing games she's like you know I
think price is one of the main reasons
we did really bad this generation
because if you look at the beginning he
look he was like Sony had nothing if we
had the game I mean he made some good
points defending you know a lot of
things a lot of questions we had the
thing I want to bring to y'all though is
the another key thing and I want to get
a look at priests thoughts on this as
well is when obviously we know about the
parent parent going on right now right
and we know you know obviously we'll
talk about we got the laser stuff going
on and he asked them specifically in
reference to hardware delivery and
software delivery in this climate right
and the thing that I got from it it's
like the exes coming regarding yes like
a vibe I got is that he said you know
China manufacturers is coming back
online they've already had their you
know contingencies that seems like that
when when Ryan pressed him about halo
Infinite I think rightly I get that but
now when he talked about halo Infinite
he made it a statement like I don't want
it to be where we have a gun to hit like
it has to come to India if it's ready
it'll be there he's happy about the
production of it now hey little infinite
Bonnie Ross and those guys in 343 right
but he didn't seem like married to it
you know and I know Brian was kinda on
the type of time I am as far as well you
know launch lineup you know important
and then he made references to things
like you know titanfall came later to
already does it so I guess I want to
bring this back to y'all and this is
gonna come with a polling like the
importance of the Halo infinitely I
think it's I'm monitoring because I
personally do think it's very important
if you're looking for it
I think I think is the difference
between them doing amazing next gender
they're doing okay but let me ask for
Capri dislike yeah I find if question
relaxed I feel halo infinite as a launch
title is critical I think this is the as
critical halo ever I think if this halo
is I've ever had right if this halo is
great this is now you can start talking
about changing the tidy and getting
mantra because you have a game what a
game not marketing a game that is
actually like 90 minute create a halo of
all you could galvanize people and if
this thing looks phenomenal
so my question you'll or Capri is like
can they get away with it that big yeah
you know because of that you know the
situation in the world today they
definitely can't and the Nintendo switch
actually for whether people like it or
not an antenna switch rewrote the book
on how to launch a system preach it
that's that is how you do it a March we
have a super hey mate yeah actually
marches what it launch with what it
allowed but like one of the greatest
games is a generation or a lot of people
with Legend of Zelda main goal I'm not
I'm not there it's probably the best
game on the switch but game what's the
importance of that game on launch with
that cop preach the word I mean Zelda's
big but like it hadn't honestly a head
so like if you look at the top selling
Zelda games they're not like quickly
this was this was an anomaly this was
something very special yes I think it
gives me hope that I was kind of wanting
to just like read King's mind a little
bit was like what did halo in Fitness
one of the best games ever made like
that's kind of like where my hype guys
it gets out of control because we what
happened on PC just over the last couple
of months when Master Chief collection
launched into steam the best game best
selling game on Steam and then they
rereleased
or they added metal off onto it and it's
like there is a thirst and a hunger for
quality Halo and people are ready for
the return just like they were ready for
zelda to come back and I think that it
is your rightness it's absolutely
critical you cannot launch the series X
without it
that I took away from the conversation
was he started talking about isn't it
bad to launch a system with like all
your games aw yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah but I feel like like
halo is the game that's the one that
launches and then you can kind of
stagger and and but I feel like halo has
been ready for a bit
I feel so - but again in this climate
here's the thing I think the date and I
want to split we're gonna talk about
this will last about I don't want to
spoil it but I think there's another
issue going on as to why you know as far
as global let's just talk retail we get
it super chastened India when we move on
we get kicking war all right clutch me
let's throw it up find out a super chat
PlayStation 5 can't take out a built-in
camera Phil said we are you got that one
all right so then we got let's see we
got a Jonathan B follow our super check
sturdy turn my notifications off this
your PlayStation 5 just make sure you
boost your home insurance because that
thing is coming in yeah yes we do we do
we do have a gamer mm-hmm what Sony
start showing these games and there's no
8.4 terrified SSD don't want to pay for
Atmos and fails to produce superior
games X gonna give it to you so will the
kids imma let you the edit and then we
gotta move on we gotta get these time
it's correct so y'all think that halo is
supposed to be the saving grace halo is
supposed to be what launches with it he
sets you like he's this whole time he's
been playing chess hmm the question he
knew that question was gonna come so are
you he's we're not married to software
his awful is right we're worried about
the user interface we're worrying about
the hardware that's one once we lock
that in and that's right we're not
ruch software we had that problem before
picking a date and sticking to it right
he knows it he's not making the same
mistakes twice
are you gonna guess why there's doomsday
that you only kill anybody once right
you guys don't get it man I'm gonna keep
giving the cheat sheet still atella
busters is that for it till you get it
right and there's a reason why you're
not gonna kill him the same way Pike
you're gonna have to do it different
nothing be a little bit better so now
let's say hallo is it ready yeah let's
say it does that six month case he gave
you the Titan full reference form yes he
did mention that he gave you that for
wieszczyk reciting for was a great game
mmm him a little bit later right right
okay so let's say this let's say what I
told you already happens mm-hmm let's
say he actually is listen he said yo
he's on to something
no he already backed that truck up he
already put that bag and he already went
over and uh he said you know project CD
red yo with every x-series system here
we go
no three months of game passes in a
month and if you have game past week
attack this onto your game pass if you
have it next you get a game pass in
there and date and date of release of
the series X my god cyberpunk 2077 oh
yeah that goes back into you you ready
leave a let's get to this part right
mmm-hmm I want anybody can tell me if
I'm wrong if I'm lying in here mmm-hmm
do you think halo will be better than
cyberpunk yes I think you might be in
the majority the minority in this and
then in that scenario left because
people Phil CD Projekt RED has been
hitting it out the park and we're coming
up up well it hasn't been the case with
halo right so y'all looking for this
halo to get some Redemption right right
let's just say he goes with the show
fire
he goes with the heavy hitter right what
makes a sound let me say sugreev migrate
to King cuz I do think cyberpunk
especially you know the team over there
CD Projekt RED they're doing a fantastic
job with their IPs but at the end of the
day cyberpunk is gonna mean a lot to the
whole industry but halo meets more to
the XX box base that's that's the whole
run right there and you you bring them
halo like mom's back ever to you oh no
like if you put them both on the same
call let's say you know they're both you
know 90 plus or Medicare they're both
loved by the community to Xbox halo into
that caliber will do more for the brand
in cyberpunk at that kind of thing so
it's a big question is this a rushed
halo won't do any or not absolutely you
know right in fact it can be a mess for
five years but being this climate that
we're in life with the ship in and yeah
right let's just say let's just say
there's a hiccup and the team can't be
in the same room we can't work in the
same family can't do the same things
that they normally do and logistically
it's not there yet it's like six months
out mmm what's the next best thing you
do I mean we don't know about the king I
mean you baby underestimate filled out
he may actually have another xbox ano
game that you know I'm saying it could
be ready
I think the coalition's game it might be
something that what about the initiative
as well but I think that there's a good
chance a what comes out because I don't
think the issue you know I know calm you
don't want to go into this but I got to
to prove my point I don't think the
issue is the development process of the
issues the distributing parts right and
I think me personally mmm I think
Microsoft will do what Sony won't do and
do a digital only release into the
physical copies come out that's it
because it you know games
y'all gonna love them oh yeah we
transition look okay before we
transition because everything which is I
want to give feel credit that no one's
really talking about is they had a
fantastic idea at Xbox showcase just
went under the radar and King for the
first time remember I told you we were
wearing a little bit about the Freestyle
we will learn worried about because his
plan got taken away as far as how to
plan his III and how to plan things
moving forward right but to see it was
no filler nobody on camera let the
phases in he kind of cringe-worthy jokes
and it was show the game had a developer
in the back lash out out to avoid Lord
Steven there and Lady Sarah David they
got the showcase for unto was updated it
was like five games that looked on fire
they were well presented quick it was
Nintendo Direct style
boom boom boom here's the next game
we're not giving you no great and if
they keep that up it was like 5b I got a
shout out these get shout to unto the
end we had to turn Studios on that
looked phenomenal
they had this game core Haven some lo
young mr. cool couple co-opted in and
look kind of cool project wingman it has
some joys like a like I almost got ace
combat drone was made by one person they
look fire skate and Excel was fine it
looked like all number 720 from back in
the day came yes it looked like an it a
new wave 720 the analogues you control
the skate it look fly the one I really
got my eye on all is just one catechin
like it is called undying so basically
you're this mother of a China zombie
apocalypse she got bitten right and you
have to train the boy your son he's like
an NPC but the boy you trained you have
to teach them to survive before the
timer goes out on your life through the
whole story the game that is emotional
but it looks fine like okay they got
some sleepers on the Indies and and
you're you're you're saying mm-hmm but
they didn't die the same way what you
mean like as far as as
far as the cringeworthy yes the
marketing has been on fire I have to
give it up to those guys so learning yes
some failed mistakes yes and the
freestyles that we was afraid of I have
to make a shot to boosting Excel you
mentioned I forgot what a higher was
anyway that enough of that I just want
to shout that out that was very
important we gonna move on
Lord addicts is we have transitioned we
talked about global distribution and all
this stuff you're up what's going on so
you know obviously with all this
fantastic news going on at Sony we had
some great more news again I can't keep
a straight face you know one of the most
highly anticipated games is generation I
would say ever is the Last of Us - and a
lot of people really hype for that me
particularly I was gonna play because I
have a another PlayStation because of
Final Fantasy I was gonna play it but
it's actually been delayed it was coming
out next month in May but now it looks
like it has been delayed indefinitely I
would assume it's been delayed to the
end of this whole you know this whole
t-virus thing going on so what I wanted
to bring to the round Britta's the
Lord's and talk to everyone about is you
know do you think this has an impact why
do you think they delayed it and you
know I wanted to get your over